from the streets of mariupol the sounds
of fierce fighting and also a voice of
defiance a ukrainian fighter appeals
directly to the presidents of the us and
france for air defense systems
you have promised there'll be help give
us that help save the civilian
population children elderly people are
dying
he finishes by comparing their plight to
the syrian city of aleppo
with much of mariupol lying in ruins and
completely surrounded by superior forces
ukraine says there is little it can do
militarily
no army in the world will be able to
cross it not even the us army with the
size of the forces we have now
unfortunately
using one of a number of humanitarian
corridors operating in the country an
exodus of people has continued telling
the same harrowing tale
there is no mario paul we sat in the
cellar for 10 days and didn't leave once
at this destroyed army base in the
southern city of mikolayev another
search for survivors there there's been
a new appeal from ukraine's president to
end the war through dialogue
but julius
i want everyone to hear me especially in
moscow the time has come to meet to talk
and as this war grinds on there's been
the competing claims of progress by both
sides the ukrainians say they've been
mounting counter-attacks and have
stopped russian forces surrounding the
capital kiev for its part russia says it
has used a new type of missile with an
attack on an installation in the west of
the country
hypersonic ballistic missiles destroyed
a big underground missile arsenal along
with aerial munitions of the ukrainian
forces
the ukrainians say overstretched russian
forces are bogged down in much of the
country and have resorted to using badly
trained recruits in the fight the
russians have released combat footage
showing that on the contrary it's the
ukrainians who are on the receiving end
rob mcbride al jazeera level